congratulations Jennifer you this is
like you know you've really grown up and
all of a sudden you're here with Brad
and the guys he's really he's really
grown up he's really grown
[Music]
I mean for us it was the story of value
and and getting second chances
people have been devalued from there by
their occupation their surroundings and
may have Worth and that's what these
guys did at that time they found this
whole pool of talent that had been
dismissed and disregarded and I think I
find that very interesting disregarded
because of a an evaluation system that
was erroneous but we've been doing it
this way for a hundred years and 150
years so it you know it makes me
question what is success what does
failure maybe it's a string of that and
we don't need to be summing each other
up and certainly summing ourselves up
from from whatever the last success or
failure was you have anything yeah I
think I think exactly I just saw it as
being undervalued and being overlooked
for not being the obvious choice for
something and that's exactly a good
metaphor of what I'm doing standing here
I believed in that I I just was really
psyched to be a part of this movie that
I really thought was gonna be something
we're all proud of than we are I have
been a victim of this gentleman's pranks
I call him the Bobby Fisher of pranks
because you try and prank him and he's
immediately three moves ahead of you
he's playing a chess game with you and
it's the preemptive strike it's the
preemptive strike and then you think of
an idea to get him back and he already
knows what you're gonna do and
retaliates before you've even spoken the
thought it's really a it's a masterful
art form with this guy and I was I guess
you would say lucky enough or just was
part of this yeah not today not today
yeah today's about celebration
[Applause]